Okay, let's see. We want a period of 1 second.
Let's convert this to an angular frequency ω using this equation.
So, we want an angular frequency of 2π, an I know that ω²
is equal to whatever this thing is, the minus something times x.
In this case, ω² is equal to g/L.  Let's solve this for L.
This gives me a length of 0.25 meters.
Now, it turns out that for pendulum clocks, actually, we might want a period of 2 seconds.
The reason is because let's say we had a pendulum with a period of 1 second.
That means that it takes 1 second for when I pull it back to go
over here and then all the way back.
That's actually quite a bit of motion and a period of 2 seconds is actually a little bit better,
because then every time the pendulum reaches one if its extrema,
either all the way over here or all the way over there,
we know 1 second has passed--half of the period.
I wonder what would be the period for a 2-second pendulum.
Why don't ask Tjeerd the clockmaker what he thinks.
[Tjeerd ] When you design a pendulum or pendulum clock,
the thing that mostly influences the period of oscillation is the length of the your pendulum.
If you have an ideal pendulum, a fictional pendulum,
made out of no materials as a mathematical piece,
the pendulum of a second, oscillating in a second,
will have a length of about a meter.
A pendulum is made out of materials, and the rod, for instance, is made out of steel or brass,
which brings the center of oscillation up.
That's why you need a heavy pendulum bulb underneath the pendulum--
to bring the center of gravity in the pendulum down
to have your proper theoretical length.